good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Monday hope
everybody had a blessed weekend a
gorgeous Mother's Day and hope
everyone's doing great speaking of
mothers hey mother
hi how you darn I'm good thank you I did
have a really great weekend great
Mother's Day fabulous it was a really
just lovely family-filled weekend it was
so important to celebrate the mothers
yes thank you 100 you sound a little
disingenuous do you not want to speak
now wow do not want to be celebrating me
not right now not right now
accusing me of not respecting
mothers
it was not disingenuine at all okay
because I didn't feel like you were a
disingenuine yesterday when you were
when I was showering you and our mother
the women who gave us life showering
with love and adoration what would make
you think I don't know I don't know it's
just like the vibe I was getting so
toxic already oh my God no but we
seriously had a great day so it's not
ruin it what are you preaching to me
please give me you I was continuing the
celebration of mothers right
well we had a great great Mother's day
and a great weekend I spent a lot of
time with my turkey yes you did and
usually after a long weekend especially
because we weren't in studio Thursday
Friday usually like if I don't see you
over the weekend like we have so much on
Monday and we really miss each other
maybe the thing is that today we don't
miss each other maybe we've like had
enough of each other I didn't feel that
way it sounded like you did we've been
in the studio for like 15 minutes and we
were having a good time we were giggling
and cackling and then he just kind of
like came at me and then the camera
comes on and the attacks begin you came
at me with this like disingenuous like
energy yeah salutation sure sure Jax god
well we do have a lot to catch up on
there wasn't a show on Friday because I
was traveling let's catch up on so many
things first of all speaking of Mother's
Day I don't know why you just can't see
the way that you keep saying it that way
no because when I kept seeing you guys
yesterday like when everybody kept
showing up to the restaurant I was like
happy Mother's Day and now it's just
it's Mother's Day got it that's why
um but speaking of Mother's Day since we
both love and respect mothers we decided
to drop a little little small little
surprise Mother's Day merch collection
at toastmarch.com we've got kids clothes
with the onesies we've got Mama's
clothes with the crewnecks they're
really cute and really sweet perfect for
the mother in your life if you're an
auntie you know whether it's blood or
spiritual yeah um so much for everyone
at toastmarch.com so much for everyone
we've never done a surprise drop like
that like no lead I lead up just like
here's the collection go shop now it's
the cutest things for your little one we
have like infant onesies that go up to
two years 24 months but then we also
have T-shirts for the toddler in your
life 2T 3T 14. I love the toddler in my
life yeah I was like an abbreviator I'm
like that's not a word
I have so many toddlers in my life who I
love yeah so is Harry toddler
you know what that's a great question
I think so
no no
or he's an infant no way I need to look
up the exact age because sometimes I
like will Google like infant coffee
which one is he baby cough he really
ain't an implant infant and you know
what he's in a toddler no he's not a
toddler you know what I think he is
rolled roll one of one yeah no but sound
off in the comments like so he's one
oh he's like 15 months yeah
what is that IDK yeah I don't know so
there's that but he could actually it's
you know what it's all making sense
because he could fit into either the
onesie or the T-shirt because
transitional I buy him like 24 months we
have the onesie for that or I could get
him 2T that's 24 months the toast we've
got a onesie for that we've got a onesie
for everything and then we have the
cutest Mama merch for yourselves
yourself I'm so excited to literally
wear everything all at once we have
really cute designs for this merch that
pair that bear it's so cute
it brings a tear to even the most
cynical of eyes the bear the podcasting
bear is on our Instagram you could see
the merge designs and I'm just obsessed
with him yeah I know you are like he's
made an obsession uh obsessed Beyond and
you know who loves him try sand
stressing
I didn't know
now you know though so there's no more
excuses the more you know
um so we haven't done an episode since
Thursday and I will say our podcast only
episode on Thursday like might have been
one of my favorites it was like so next
level like more on it it was so crazy I
didn't remember anything that was
discussed until people were messaging me
yesterday being like four yeah right can
you remind me like where four comes from
so it was just great we were both like
Delirious because we recorded it
Wednesday night
um but it's been a while since we've
seen you guys back in studio feels so
good and you know I've been traveling a
lot these last three weeks like I'm good
now my travels are done and I'm just
like back to Jackson Claude OJ recipe in
the studio yeah and what's better than
that same for me like I've been here and
there and everything all over and I'm
I'm ready to settle down yeah yeah
um so I was in Frisco on Thursday
Wednesday Thursday Friday for the ACM
Awards Academy of Country Music I
vlogged the whole experience so if you
want to head over to patreon.com toast
it's already up you can see that's why I
feel fully recapped on it and debrief
because the Vlog went up on Friday went
up on Friday it covers the gamut of the
weekend and it was so good and really
your vlogging skills are improving every
day you know I was proud of this one and
I feel like on my turnaround time lately
for the Vlogs has been like if I don't
like do something the second it needs to
be done it'll be months 100 if I don't
answer a text right when I get it yep
years so that's why on both my plane
ride home from Nashville and my plane
ride home from Dallas I edited the blogs
so they've been really timely Pat me on
the back thank you and the whole recap
is there but I just want to say me and
Margo had the best time at the ACM
Awards the Vlog covers like red carpet
Glam actual interviews on the red carpet
all of our interview
um
footage which we usually do our live
stream which like lives on YouTube
Forever which is so fun was on the
Amazon fashion Snapchat so for those who
caught it I hope you enjoyed it was so
much fun and I'm so happy to be home
we're happy to have you but it was
really fabulous and I like the way that
I looked you know which is so so risky
you know it's such a gap like 50 50. not
only when you're just you know a human
being putting on clothes but also your
human being wearing an updo
and you're Claudia ashrae where yeah
updo oh yeah stepping out of her box up
to gate which we spoke about at length
leading up to the actual award shows
updo gate was kind of the whole
Chronicle the whole journey was
chronicled in the Vlog so you'll see the
highs the lows you know the haircut I
cut
my hair like with scissors well I didn't
Anna the gorgeous patreon member stylist
did who loves toast radio she loves
toast radio she said she loved it it's
one of her favorite episodes and her
husband loved it too they listened to it
on a long car ride so we're just like
bringing couples together literally
um so yeah I won't spoil too much of the
Vlog but it was just a great weekend
thanks for giving me the day off on
Friday Jax I was not okay and I
don't even know when I would have
vlogged because I'll know the plane
um and I also think after this Vlog like
I might end up on a no-fly list yeah for
sure there's a breakdown in the airport
bathroom if anybody airplane bathroom
airplane bathroom if anyone was standing
outside the door like you would have
ended up I was a watch list I was
concerned that like my screaming was
they're gonna alert me imagine you were
waiting for the bathroom and you heard a
girl screaming in the in there and she's
by herself and she's vlogging no but
like you don't know she's vlogging so
yeah she walked she walks out you've
just heard her screaming like maybe she
like got into a fight with someone and
she's by herself yeah no it was just one
of those days where like everything was
bothering me like even like the clothes
on my my back were like itching my skin
like I was just so irritable and I just
had to document it for the Vlog because
I'm such an authentic content creator
and that's what you guys saw on the
Vlogs you're gonna see highs and lows
you're going to see breakdowns in
Airplane bathrooms and you're seeing
glamorous curls on the red carpet it's
true you can't have one without the
other and that's called being Dynamic
and being authentic authentic I think
you are extremely authentic thank you so
much Jackie that was kind of your
takeaway from the Vlog from watching it
yeah I didn't feel like there was things
that you weren't telling us or things
that you were holding back you didn't
feel like there were any inauthentic
moments no I didn't feel like you were
putting on airs yeah I felt like we were
there with you that's good
yeah I felt just like the satchel right
just along for the ride it was a
satchel-filled weekend it was we got so
much satch this weekend so much Satchel
time and I were so grateful oh and then
I got home on Friday and I went to
stassi shorter's live show you did she
busy I was so busy
um she is on tour doing like a live
podcast live show with her husband and
Taylor strucker so their show was in New
York I met so many toasters it's
fabulous and it was so much fun so I
really just had like a crazy busy
weekend you did Crazy Girl
and I watched Ted lasso
I was watching it and I just like am not
pulled enough to keep like I will fit I
will keep watching it
um it's just like I'm not obsessed that
like oh my God I have to go home and
finish it that keeps you on your toes no
but like you just want to keep watching
more and more because you love the
characters I found the season to be like
kind of womb womp and I've loved it in
the past I don't know what it I agree I
already said this on the show because I
was saying like I don't know if the show
is changed a little or like I've changed
but
um it's just not like doing for me what
it used to do it's certainly this season
is not as good as seasons pass but it's
still a great show that's like fun and
easy to watch and doesn't give you a pit
you know yeah yeah but there's just like
a lot of extra verbiage there's a lot of
also Nate
Nate but at least
he's like interest you never know what
he's gonna do but like I feel like the
the dialogue is getting really verbose
wordy yeah with all their like jokes
that they don't stop making and it's
like it's not that funny like I feel
that like honestly like Ted like he's so
yeah yeah he's just like for something
that could be a one-word answer he it's
a word salad from him like every time
yeah yeah yeah I do like that they've
brought in some of our like favorite
characters and made them even bigger
like Staples like Trent Crim the
independent he now like works for the
team or whatever he's like shadowing the
team
um and he was like my me and Ben's like
favorite character like every time he
would stand up and say Trent Crim then
he's still he doesn't say Trent crimley
independent no but is he still your
favorite character yeah you learn more
about him and he like develops a
friendship with someone on the team and
like it's really sweet okay cute yeah no
it's still good
but also like with keel
Keeling Jack no oh Roy right yeah yeah
yeah yeah there's more that happens it's
just wrong I agree it's like why so like
what are we watching for what are we
doing here yeah yeah
um and then it also started the new
season of the other two which is that
show I've been telling you to watch
um and they like they skip three years
in the future
I don't know why because I think maybe I
discovered the show I think that a new
season hasn't come out since before
kovid
so they like skip over covid but they
like do flashbacks because like Carrie
was filming a movie it was actually very
funny like covered stuff
um but I was like so confused
okay yeah I'm sorry it didn't even say
three years later you were confused we
mean that we're just confused I'm sorry
it's okay I've been watching working
moms too so good right it's good but
it's like a little dark what part what
season are you on still first season oh
like
it's real Jax it's real it is real but
like there's it's a little like I expect
it to be a little more like
light-hearted and yeah they're just it's
like Jenny is like uh like oh that Jenny
that Storyline by the way she goes away
for a while okay and then um Kate like
takes a job in Montreal and and she's
running back and forth well she just had
her first day and she had to and she
already flew home to like be with her
son in the hospital and it was just like
dark and then and it's the best oh yeah
I think she's probably my favorite
character but like she was pregnant and
like then she didn't want another kid oh
yeah and it's just like yeah I will say
I forgot about that because there's like
six years of course crazy pants Frankie
she stabilizes like she becomes like the
most stable like I forgot that that the
early seasons of the show I guess they
are like kind of crazy because it does
level out and just become like a show
about working moms you know yeah yeah
but I forgot about crazy ass pants Zoe
Jenny whatever her kid's name is Zoe So
Kate's her kid yeah yeah so I don't know
it's stick with it though I will I will
it's so it's like so cute and I think at
like certain points once it levels out
like you'll find it extremely relatable
there are moments like there are certain
like Niche things that
you could only like really I would never
have appreciated like until I was a mom
um so I I enjoy that but I'm just like
these storylines man like Darkness
Darkness okay that's such a fair
criticism for a show that's like a
light-hearted comedy.com yeah totally
right right
um so it was a great weekend it's gonna
be a great episode there's lots to
discuss let's talk about you know
the attempted cancellation of Miss Kelly
Clarkson we'll we'll get into it in
depth not on my watch but just know uh
like a little teaser for what's about to
come like we are not here for it not on
my watch what we're not gonna do is
bring down America's sweetheart the
loveliest woman in daytime that's what
we're not gonna do via the actions of
someone else completely Yeah by proxy
but we keep putting Kelly's face in the
article and Kelly's name in the headline
wrong we're gonna talk about it we're
gonna talk about lots of going on in the
Taylor Swift Universe this weekend yeah
it's like every day there's just like
something to talk about with Taylor and
it's like I just can't tell you how much
joy that brings me like I will not tire
there was like definitely like a year
maybe like a few months ago where like
not a there was like a few months like
maybe a year ago where we like could not
stop talking about the Kardashians it
comes and goes with celebrities like
we're in our Taylor press era and I
couldn't be happier and this week you
know what's been so interesting
especially now that she's
hitting up the New England you know
Eastern seaborg between every weekend
she's in New York and she's hitting up
the fabulous spots she's loving a
members Club she's gone to Casa Cipriani
she's gone to zero Bond I have plans
every night this week because I will see
Taylor like I'm going to Carbone like
I'm gonna see Taylor do you think that's
where she'll go I don't know maybe
she'll go back to the clubs yeah I know
I know I just I gotta go like you kind
of just need to like get dressed and
stay on alert and then just like have
people like DM you tips I I honestly
just described like the worst night of
my life yeah or like dressed and stay on
alert like no I'd rather I'd like to
just like let you know if she gets a
sighting so you can run down because
like an ideal night for me is to get
undressed and stay on alert you know and
like with my eyes closed but for
tailored for tailored I would do it I'm
going out every night this week for
tailored what are you doing she's got
plans you know yeah
cool well thanks for the invite
I couldn't make it but I would have
loved to be there okay like I don't
really have that many plans I have like
one night I have like one dinner and I'm
just like hoping that she'll be there
what is it just dinner you can't say
well like is it was that Carbone yeah
you you're hoping she'll be at the
restaurant not like at your dinner I
know I don't know if you're at my table
maybe we're invited to an event that you
think she might go to okay wait
wait wait wait I just thought of
something the person who I'm having
dinner with is actually like a close
personal friend of Taylor Swift
oh yeah so if she let's just say let's
just say she was at the restaurant like
she would come up to my table 100
but like that person might also be like
meeting up in New York because they're
both in New York oh wait wait like that
person might know what maybe I should
have dinner with this person every night
of the week yeah
hmm
so I think yeah
um so should we dive in yeah we've
deleted and we've dallied we have so
without further Ado here are the first
time stories that you need to know and
today's episode is brought to you by
chamberlaincoffee introducing
Chamberlain coffey's new ready to drink
collection inspired by Emma
Chamberlain's daily cold brew recipe
Chamberlain coffee just launched four
plant-based latte flavors in a can that
are available exclusively at Walmart you
shake well and serve cold for the best
coffee experience so everyone loves
Chamberlain coffee the canned coffee is
now available at Walmart you can get it
at walmart.com they come in four
different flavors and it just requires
no effort you know it's in a can and I
think things that require no effort like
we should support those initiatives and
this is one of them we have them here at
the studio whenever everybody comes in
we're like want a coffee we actually
have coffee to offer them it's really
nice and they've you know been very well
received thus far so all four lattes are
vegan they're made with almond and
coconut milk which is so Emma they're
naturally sweetened with date syrup they
contain only one gram of sugar per can
and they're free from artificial flavors
and preservatives so the flavors in
include the Cobra latte a mocha latte
cinnamon bun latte and a vanilla latte
the cinnamon bun latte is just really
chef's kiss I love coffee that doesn't
taste like coffee you know what I'm
saying I'm not really like a big you
know fan of like you know itself and
like sniffing the beans being the yetis
came from a region in Colombia you know
I'm not one of those people
um you could take your favorite Cobra
lattes on the go anytime anywhere you
can have coffee on hand to grab in
seconds no preparation required leave
them in your office fridge leave them in
your fridge at home we've got tons at
the studio just good to have you know
you never know when you're gonna need it
you never know for a limited time our
listeners can get a free Chamberlain
coffee latte when they purchase a can
terms and conditions applied visit
chamberlaincoffee.com the toast for
offer details again that's
offer details today's episode is also
brought to you by honey
the easy way to save on save money when
shopping on your iPhone or computer
thanks to Honey manually searching for a
coupon code is a thing of the past honey
is the free shopping tool that scours
the internet for promo codes and applies
the best one it finds to your cart so
thanks to the toasters we've been known
about honey long before since they
started sponsoring our podcast we've
kind of known for being like early
adapters to Fabulous things and honey is
one of them it's a free browser
extension that you download for free
when you use our link and it just you
know I don't know how browser extensions
work but they just go they like attach
to your internet browser and then every
time you're shopping I've saved money on
makeup food Electronics clothing of
course every time you're shopping you're
like forget it's even there and then the
second before you press check out
they're like hey girlie want to save
money you click apply coupons honey does
its thing the little coin dances while
it finds coupon codes he's got some good
moves and then next thing you know
random promo code is saving you 15 off
on your outfit for an engagement party
you have this weekend which is exactly
what happened to me
so you'll wait a few seconds honey we'll
search the internet for coupons you can
find and then you'll watch the price
drop if they find a working coupon and
what's so exciting we've been using
honey for years on our laptops but now
honey works on your iPhone so it works
on your iPhone just activated on your
Safari on your phone and save on the go
if you don't already have honey you're
straight up missing out and by getting
it you're doing yourself a solid and
supporting the toast get PayPal honey
for free at joinhoney.com toast that's
joinhoney.com toast thank you Claudia
happy shopping you're gonna you're gonna
be so rich after honey are you ready for
our first story
no actually I'm not you're not I just
don't feel like contributing to this you
know toxic narrative around Kelly
Clarkson it's actually not going to be
our first story because that's just I
don't want to give it that air like I
want to start with I agree I want to
start we're burying the story burying it
like I love not the most important story
I agree I would say the big story of
this morning are the Sports Illustrated
models
four Cover Girls we have Martha Stewart
at 81 becomes the oldest woman to cover
Sports Illustrated Megan Fox Brooks
Nader and Kim Petrus each have their own
cover so I have to say I like I'm the
father that Martha Stewart's 81 like she
you know she has like the body her
body's amazing and she looks like an
older woman she does not look 81 yeah
she really looked so fabulous like they
really styled her to Perfection just
like rich older woman she has like big
sunglasses and diamonds in the water
it's very on brand for Martha I really
love this selection I know it never
would have even crossed my mind honestly
no but she Martha's such a queen like
name a woman who has a better repute
name a woman who's gone to prison who
has a better reputation than Martha
Stewart I'll wait
I don't think I can right
I don't think I can she's an inspiration
she is she is looking so great I love
her the cover photo the best for her me
too but I also love the one when she's
in the water with like this big
obviously like million dollar necklace
yeah but the ones without the glasses I
like better oh okay she looks fabulous
um and I'm here for it now how do you
feel about four Cover Girls this is a
good thing they do
um it's not my favorite thing that
they're doing I would stand like
everyone's a winner I make a choice you
know I do long for the days people from
becoming like the Sports Illustrated
girly who like then a careers right
catapulted because also it's like Brooks
Nader is the only like model like right
model who by trade by trade everyone
else is a celebrity yeah so it's like
it's not gonna do anything crazy for
their careers it's just like cool yeah I
do long for the days like there were a
few years where like they would select
an uh not unknown but like a very much
on the rise we hadn't heard of them but
like if you were a modeling Scout you
might have where they would choose one
girl and it would like change the
trajectory of the girl life
um that's how we got Kate Upton that's
how that's how we got Hannah Davis Jeter
there was like you know it was really
like a big honor and it would change
your life and then slowly like then they
had that Chrissy Teigen Nina agdala he
had three girls but that was so cool it
was good and now it's it's gives like
you know participation energy
um and it's not gonna change the life of
one girl and make that girl like the
next big it model
um I love all these covers like I don't
have a problem with any of these
participants but I do like I liked when
they would just kind of like put their
you know like how the queen would deny
so much they would just Knight like
you're the next big thing and it would
be exciting to see who they chose yeah I
still enjoy all their content and they
really do a good job of like choosing
people from the internet they don't like
shy away from like Instagram modely
energy
um but yeah I I do I do long for those
days yeah it was a cool thing yeah and
this is a different cool thing yeah
Martha Stewart on the cupboard of the
sports it's fabulous it's very cool like
Kim was on the cover last year yeah and
also then all these covers become so
unmemorable it's like yes we remember
all those covers probably up until
Hannah Jeter no okay remember when Kate
Upton got three covers yep but like they
were so like crazy and sexy and like her
tits were just not to be like disgusting
but like they were just like voluptuous
and she was here like she was really out
here representing the Big Titty
Committee and like and then Hannah Jeter
where her bathing suit like was almost
off of her vagina like they are
memorable and I remember the three girls
and I've definitely forgotten some some
I remember what I've forgotten a lot I
don't even remember what Kim's looked
like yeah ever it looks like her
Instagram ever since we've had a
hodgepodge Mania yeah we're at the
Sports Illustrated covers I can't think
of the last iconic one that I've seen
but I will say I think Megan Fox's is
stunning is the best of this year yeah
she looks insane I love the bathing suit
or whatever outfit whatever it is I
think she looks great yeah no there's I
don't have a critique of any of the
selects or any of the photos but it does
seem like a little
come here yeah
you know yeah but like if they are gonna
do four it's a great four grade four but
let's like the four but I'm team one I'm
team one as well but if I have to play
on Team Four okay great yeah I I want to
be like gbt make a prediction okay
actually no I that's a bad prediction I
take it back well because I was gonna
say like honestly Sierra from summer
house is like in her modeling era like
she should be next year but she just
signed a thing with Victoria's Secret
that's why I was like in my brain and
she would never she can do both got it I
also am curious to see who's gonna be on
the inside of the magazine anymore the
rookies are for next year
and I don't think they're gonna go back
to one no no no if anything they'll be
six
there'll be six because for a while it
was like three yeah
then four and you know what happens
after four
what
mind blown yeah I told you four is a
tricky number I know
I know
but it's one they chose it's the one
they got and it's one we got and they
all look great
should have been us but you know
how frightening would that be yeah
yeah
trust him away nobody needs to see that
yeah and then I wonder where does
everybody need to see that no I think
I think if they shot me from like the uh
breasts up I would do it yeah I want to
see the inside of like the rest I'm not
gonna get the magazine and I also wonder
like how sales are when it's four do
they actually care who sells the most or
it's just like I totally forgot that
this was like a print initiative I know
because also I just I now I'm realizing
I've been seeing some people people post
Sports Illustrated like announcements
all year long yeah and I never know like
when the cover is coming right no
because I follow Melissa wood and she
was a rookie or some she's included this
year
um so I've been like following her
journey for like literally months I
follow Nicole Williams English from Wags
she's a model and she's pregnant this
year and she did Sports Illustrated
pregnant and the pictures were awesome
it didn't dawn on me that like oh when
we're waiting for the cover right right
right because when there's it's like a
little bit of a letdown when there's
like so much hoopla all year so it's
like it's not this big reveal and
there's four and then also you have the
people posting their old pictures so I'm
like what's new is this current like but
here it is that's like a storyline on
the other two so he gets like one movie
okay and he posts happy one month since
Night Nurse came out literally he's like
all these drafts scheduled to like the
one year anniversary and he's like
losing followers like mad and his mom
literally has to sit him down and be
like you have to stop posting like for
all the cast mates happy birthday beanie
feldstein loved working with you on
Night Nurse that's his Molly Shannon
sits him down it's like you have to make
me a promise like you she gives him a
hundred thousand dollars because he's
being blackmailed she's like I'll give
you this money but you had to stop
posting about Night Nurse and that's
like that's it's so real that's what
people do who have like one thing and
they wish every cast man happy birthday
or somebody gets married and they're
like congratulations
love working with you on Night Nurse
yeah it's so funny that is really funny
when you watch his followers like drop
every time he posts it's so funny
well congrats to all the models and
celebrities and the grads
and the grads they're still graduating
yeah they are that they are what are
your thoughts on the college graduation
weekends being over Mother's Day
I mean I can understand there's only so
many weekends and all the colleges have
to split them but as a mother now like
it's wrong but it's also like you're
celebrating your kid it forces the
family to be together it's actually like
I was thinking about that this weekend
because I saw people I follow Jessica
Seinfeld and she was out at Duke with
her daughter so they were two birds one
stone yeah I was like oh that's
interesting that you know graduation is
on Mother's day but is it so bad the
family's all together
taking a trip to North Carolina or
wherever it is as long as this ceremony
is not unsung
as long as the ceremonies not on Sunday
yes let's talk about worse human
experiences than sitting through the the
calling of the names sitting through a
graduation period we unless it's like a
middle school that seems like cute to me
oh yeah adorable
I feel like even high school I feel like
just College graduations because like
your family hasn't been around for any
of it it's like where are we who are
these people yeah like what can you get
like four tickets and like everyone's
Grandma Aunts Uncles and third cousin
comes in and like Waits outside yeah no
for your graduation was Far and Away the
worst one because Olivia Margot and I
all went to NYU and they do it by school
so it's like it's much smaller and at
least like we don't have to travel
anywhere like it was just like a
torturous afternoon yours was a
torturous weekend and the actual
graduation was like thousands and
thousands of people it's like a real
college graduation for sure but it's
actually a small school
compared to yes University of Michigan
but like compared to NYU it's enormous
because like we would be it would be
done by School in NYU like we went to
The Beacon Theater Beacon Theater only
seats like a thousand people
okay your thing was in like a massive it
was on the lawn you know no it was in um
like the sports center right it was
huge and did they call the names
yeah they called they called the name so
we waited till mine and then we and God
forbid you know our name was spelled
Ashley no it's ocean with an O at least
it's not zosuri okay it might as well
have been honestly to wait till oh
I think I weren't married wine rub oh my
god oh uh but it was a fun weekend yeah
yeah we got lit I agree this ceremony is
just Dreadful Dreadful
never-ending Dreadful I'm so glad we're
like out of that phase of our lives like
we're all graduated from college yeah
well happy happy graduation grads yeah I
hope you enjoy your ceremonies now that
we've ruined it
are you ready for our next story no
because I will not participate in the
tearing down of a successful woman so
overall not today I won't over the
weekend or was it yeah like Friday
Friday an article dropped that the Kelly
Clarkson show is a traumatizing
workplace run by monster
one monster right and so when you read
that headline who would you assume is
the monster at the top of the Kelly
Clarkson show
who would you assume knowing but not
what you know about Kelly
Kelly right and also who would you
assume given like everything we've
learned about some problematic daytime
talk show hosts over the last few years
right so I was actually thinking last
night like I will go back and watch our
dissection of the The Ellen report and
compare it to our dissection of the
Kelly report but the thing is like Ellen
being like a mean person is like the
most believable narrative Kelly being
evil is quite literally unbelievable
Kelly would have to walk up to me and
punch me in the face even then even
though it says it was it was involuntary
spasm no even then I would say I
probably needed it yeah no like for real
but anyways Rolling Stone like dropped
an expose about the Kelly Clarkson show
it's toxic behind the scenes staffers
say accordingly they're overworked and
underpaid according to 11 Kern and
former employees the talk show host is
fantastic but a number of the show's
producers make employees lives hell
so they reiterate a few times throughout
the article that they that the staffers
think that Kelly has no idea about like
people being unhappy in her workplace
but that there is like a top producer
who's just known for making the
workplace miserable she's worked on
other shows and done this like and the
staffers are sometimes like crying on
like in the stairwell or on the roof or
something on the roof right they said on
the roof I I did read the stairwell but
perhaps the roof as well there are only
so many places that you can get right I
remember going up on the roof of the
stage to cry being like Oh my gosh what
am I doing why am I putting myself
through this I just want to say for that
particular anecdote they didn't share
what sent her to the room right to cry
um so there's just like a lot of
crying Rod sweeping accusations I didn't
get a lot of in like exact instances of
what um what the crimes were when you
compare it to Ellen there were like so
many instances of like the exact she
made fun of my nail polish like people
sharing the anecdotes with so many
details yeah
um so and I just don't buy it Kelly has
an executive producer whose name is Alex
dutta and the staffers are like kind of
attributing all of it to her while
Kelly's face is on the article and her
name is in the headline right and God
forbid they put Alex Duda in the
headline they said former employees say
the toxic Behavior behind the scenes
starts with Dada who Shields Clarkson
from what staffers say they're enduring
because of the climate data created the
former employee says quote I think dutt
is a monster I have really hard to like
read this article yeah I have a friend
who's an executive producer who warned
me about taking this job but apparently
she has done this on every show that
she's worked on
so sounds like the article is more um an
analysis on the data workplace as
opposed to the Clarkson workplace and I
don't appreciate you know anyone using
Kelly's good name to boost their article
I don't no I don't but here's some more
quotes because this uh former employee
says Kelly is fantastic she's a person
who never treats anyone with anything
but dignity as it and is incredibly
appreciative I would be shocked if she
knew I'd be floored if she knew the
staff wasn't getting paid for two weeks
of Christmas Hiatus oh damn the Kelly
that I interacted with and everyone
knows would probably be a gas to learn
that yeah and one former employee says
they recently quit working at the show
because a producer who reports to Dada
yelled and cursed at them multiple times
on stage they say they develop so much
anxiety from the way they were treated
at work that they would regularly vomit
and exhibit physical signs of sickness
they say the job deteriorated my mental
health
well it's good that she quit it's not
okay
um
a second former employee says they took
a leave of absence because their mental
health was also suffering they say they
were bullied and intimidated by
producers who went out of their way to
make staffers feel scared to ask
questions and get their work done
according to the staffer this prompted
them to take a month away from the job
and see a psychiatrist for the first
time in their life because they truly
couldn't handle it mentally then you
also have to think about like what work
they're doing at the Kelly Clarkson show
right it seems It's like they're in the
Marines right right yelling and they're
screaming and it's like girl we're just
singing in the middle of the day we're
Kelly oakying we're waiting to five
o'clock in the middle of the day like
stop yelling yeah no people need to calm
no down I think like everyone really
needs to like constantly be reminding
themselves no matter what it is like
it's not that deep like why are you
yelling like why is this such a high
pressure work environment right this is
a joyful daytime talk show hosted by
America's sweetheart like calm down
producers calm down that's such a good
point I'm sure there's a lot of work
that goes into a show and so much behind
the scenes but like Kelly gets on and
she lights up and a conversation takes
place like let the chips fall whether I
mean you don't need to like micromanage
Kelly micromanage people and like yell
at them on their power trip
about your little singing show no that's
the thing with like human nature but
also I think people who like work in
entertainment it's like the first taste
of power like they turn into monsters
well that's kind of people in general
yeah but I also think that like what
they think that they're doing on these
shows is so important and like we have
to make this this is like everyone just
calm down yeah the show will go on the
show yeah because Kelly's a pro right
and as long as we have Kelly like we
need not be yelling we need not be yelly
yelly Clarkson no so I feel bad for
Kelly I woke up on Saturday she released
a statement put out like some text on
font right and said like that she had no
idea and obviously like that she doesn't
stand for any of this of course we knew
that she didn't we didn't think that she
did I never once would think oh yeah
this is like a Kelly approved
environment no no
but I just I you know I I really I don't
take lightly the usage of Kelly's name
and likeness
to generate clicks for this story but I
also feel like
it's the only way for these people to be
heard to be heard because they did Lodge
tons of complaints with HR that didn't
um change the tone of the workplace and
like how does that happen rmhr agencies
like in place so things like this don't
happen and NBC this like the most
corporate ass like you can't you
know everything is on record what's the
point right like HR like do your
literally do your job yeah
so I guess if there was an article that
came out like Alex is a mean boss we'd
be like who we wouldn't make it
to the Fast Five so they have to use
Kelly's name invisibility I get it but I
don't appreciate it no I don't
appreciate it either because I will not
I will not join this bandwagon like I
will not because people just read this
article just read this headline like
move on with their lives and then see it
posted everywhere else it gets picked up
it was a rolling stone exclusive but it
gets picked up everywhere we'll just now
move forward like thinking Kelly
Clarkson is a mean woman yeah and I
don't take that lightly and I know that
that's not true same
I just know it in my bones I know and
also like they're literally saying that
she's not and you know what they're
literally saying in the article Kelly is
the nicest sweetest person she's exactly
who you think she is she has no idea
this is going on but let me tell you
something like I love Kelly and like I
didn't even read the article like I like
no one reads the article no I read the
article so that I could know so I could
have viewed it so that I could have
Kelly's back yeah yeah
ready to defend Kelly we just wrote
Defending and thankfully there was
nothing in there that was independental
question my stanhood even the smallest
but anything we stand harder than we did
before because they're they're saying
she's an amazing person and this is a
transitional time for Kelly be reported
last week her show was permanently
moving to 30 Rock in New York and I
think it's a great time to shake things
up Shake It Up Chicago get rid of Alex
hire us and we'll we'll get that place
running like a well-oiled machine for
sure but I also feel like this Alex
woman I mean she's not a public figure
she didn't respond to their questions
for comment but like
if if Kelly's talking to all her
producers like it's a conversation like
what the going on like she might
be like these people were literally so
terrible right right they couldn't get
like one plus one equal sock done like
someone has to move and shake them right
um give her a chance like I would I
would like to hear her side of the story
I would like to too but it also sounds
like this is just like this is her Mo
and perhaps why she's so successful that
she got this job and she's done this at
other places it's like her thing yeah
like she's like a wench monster yeah but
sometimes it takes a wench monster to
get a show all the Emmys and all the
success and accolades that Kelly's has
had thus far yeah but for me I'm just
like no Kelly's the reason for the
season obviously because there are some
shows that are like it feels more like
um Ensemble you know like but this is
like this show is a success because of
Kelly's heart and soul agreeing and
voice and I would argue that
so much of the success of Kelly show has
to do with their presence on social
media like whoever's running that
department is clearly like a young like
with it person they absolutely crush it
you should hear from that person they're
the reason why like Kelly's so relevant
on Tick Tock now why people like Flock
to her covers and like her the videos of
her like covering her karaoke goes so
viral I want to hear from that person
because they work for the workplace yeah
but they're very good at their job
what's their experience been like I
would love to hear from them as well
I'll find them on LinkedIn care comment
for the toast
do it I've done it already it's been
done
if you know the person who does Kelly
social reach out to us we'll keep it
private we're just curious yeah
we're just nosy yeah we are curious we
have to get to the bottom of this in
order to clear our girl's name right
you're not going to drag her through the
mud and we're going to sit back and not
ask questions
right
leave Kelly alone
yeah
I just I can't believe she had to like
wake up and post that I know she's like
at a really unique place in her life
where she's so unbelievably successful
and famous and she's never had to post
like a words note app like statement
screenshot and I hate that we've gotten
to this place yeah and I think it's more
of a statement on society that we got to
a place where Kelly Clarkson had to do
that and act at such like a low brow
like disgusting level of behavior
um it's just it's it's it's a stunning
indictment on the culture it is it is it
is
oh are you ready for our next story yeah
Taylor Swift puts a pause on Bad Blood
to tell a security guard to lay off a
fan at a Philadelphia show well actually
I think the whole point of why the story
went so viral is that she didn't pause
because baby now we got bad blood hey
you know we used to get mad hey stop she
wasn't doing anything she literally
didn't stop she didn't pause stop so
Taylor's going viral she goes viral
every weekend for some cute moment or
this or that at the show she gave the
the hat to Bejeweled yeah but oh and by
the way we got more information because
you and I were talking about like what
does it mean if he like used her Corey
she used his choreography like and he
was making a lot of tick tocks this
weekend saying you know uh as a part of
you know him using her dance he got free
tickets
um but he also said that they have
Taylor nation which is Taylor's
management company had reached out to
him before the era's tour began and
asked for his approval to use his
choreography to which he said
emphatically yes that's very sweet yeah
so they you know crossed all their eyes
and doubted all their T's totally
um so she went viral this weekend
because she was performing bad blood and
she saw something off stage I guess what
a fan was being like harassed yeah just
getting in trouble with the security
guard and Taylor was like seeing the
situation and seeing that the fan did
nothing right she did nothing wrong
right and uh by the way that was a
perfect
um so like she literally is talking to
the security guard yelling at him in the
middle of bad blood in between the
lyrics and then the security guard was
escorted out and then the girl spoke out
what did she say she let everyone know
that of course Taylor gives her her
tickets for the following night which
was last night to relive The Experience
because it was ruined and she just said
like we were just like living like we
were jumping and screaming and dancing
and we were touching like the barricade
and like every time we would come within
an inch like this guy was just like he
had it like out for us and was just like
harassing us like we were just being
joyful and lovely and everyone around us
was like what the like he just had
it out for us and then being a stickler
he was being a stickler like for nothing
for yeah and she was like shookith when
Taylor noticed you know like there's
it's crazy 70 000 people in a stadium
I mean this weekend was like so crazy
for Taylor she did three shows which
some weekends she does too she did three
in Philly obviously Pennsylvania is her
home state so like maybe there's more
Fanfare for her there and each night
there was like between 10 and 20 000
people standing outside the stadium just
listening that's crazy that is crazy I
probably could have done like 10 shows I
read somewhere I don't know if this is
true like if she actually met the demand
for every single person who wanted a
ticket she would have to do 900 stadium
shows
that's crazy that's crazy
but Philly in in particular this weekend
was nuts I think that's also because
Philly's like a little nuts you know
Grease the polls yeah no and they like
they're hard for for something that
they're passionate about it's true they
do they feel strongly about their
passions yep and passionately about them
right and they take their passion
projects seriously which is something we
relate to right on a deep level right so
it was like uh wound up being a good
moment for Taylor but you could actually
see she was like pissed and it felt like
it like through her it would have thrown
me like yeah to like be like and I don't
think she thought I mean everything she
does in every show like literally every
burp like goes viral right but it's
become so it's not just going viral in
the the Swifty you know it's like it's
national news and I think it's national
news because the way she did it was like
low-key bunny like she's so professional
like she did not stop the song but she
was like she stayed on beat she likes
the beat and now it's become you know it
used to be mad love hey stop she wasn't
doing anything like it was it was
musical yeah it was it had a nice ring
to it it did I wonder of people now at
the following shows are going to start
singing there's certain things in the
Swifty Community where like if you're in
the know like when she sings delicate at
a certain point everybody you know
chance one two three let's go what
is that oh it's I've seen some captions
it was very my caption someone else too
someone else in your group it was a very
organic thing I don't know how it
exactly started I think somebody just
filmed a video of themselves at the
reputation concert and she was like is
it cool that I said oh that is it
because you know that it's delicate and
the guy was just like one two three
let's go and then it started to
spread so much and people just started
saying it themselves and now it's like
at the concert at that point in delicate
you just say it in Bad Blood it's just
become a thing where she's like
Band-Aids don't fix bullet holes you say
sorry just for show if you live like
that you live with ghosts and then she
did a remix
um with Kendrick Lamar and so everybody
always said you forgive you forget but
you never let it go out to the whole
crowd now it's just like a thing people
do there's just like and now it's going
to become a thing where she's like baby
now we got bad but stop she wasn't doing
anything yeah I'm calling it people are
gonna start doing that they should 100
it's hilarious they should but also
Taylor's making just she's all over the
headline she was with Matt Healy in New
York all weekend like these two are
dating it's not AI generated they're
dating deal with it and he was at the
shows he was sitting in a suite actually
with her parents there's like that VIP
tent on the floor Jennifer Lawrence was
there this weekend Nicole Kidman Keith
Urban
um Gigi I think went again uh Bo Burnham
was there just you know feeling even
more rumors that he's dating Phoebe
Bridgers
um Blake Lively and the kids so it was
like a star-studded affair got it and he
was he was not in the tent he was in a
suite yeah that was my point yeah he
went up to a sweet maybe he wants to sit
down yeah yeah and her mom was there too
and you know so many good songs came out
of this weekend I was particularly
crushed forever and always that's like
one of my favorites but you know I love
forever and always but I really love
forever and always the piano version and
with the secret song she does one guitar
and one piano and I think she did
forever and always on the guitar which I
would have loved the piano version but
whatever I wasn't even there
um she did Gold Rush which there were a
couple songs Gold Rush that people could
have guessed Gold Rush was one of them
with my Eagles t-shirt hanging from your
door and people were never sure if she
meant Eagles football team or Eagles the
band but this pretty much confirmed she
meant football team and yesterday was
Mother's Day and you know Taylor is
obsessed with her mom and she wrote the
best tape for her mom and she's saying
she sang it and she cried and like
honestly I got like choked oh my God I
haven't seen the video yoga choked up
too I would I would get so choked up
yesterday was the best day I know it's
such a great Mother's Day song but it's
too it's too good it's too raw when she
got choked up when she was like Daddy
smart oh no and you're I can't remember
it you're the prettiest lady in the
whole wide world it was so freaking cute
you know she like loves her mom and like
it was just
that's really cute I'm sure there were a
lot of mothers and daughters there
together like Bethany and her daughter
went yes Bethany was making so much
content she enjoyed herself I'm glad
which is like hard for her these days
she has to criticize everything but she
didn't have anything bad to say oh Brian
the point guy was at the show on um
Saturday hard launching his new
boyfriend I don't know if everybody saw
it on Instagram I was shook I was like
okay we're just hard launching and he
was like what does that mean everyone's
saying it to me I'm like oh God I'll
call you later
um and he was I spoke to him yesterday
he was like I went deaf like he and I
guess like when we were in the suite
like we missed like maybe a lot of the
noise he was like there was one point
after champagne problems where like
everyone was cheering he was like I
thought my eardrum was going to burst he
was like I was plugging my ears it was
the craziest thing and Brian was just
like it was so crazy to see someone have
like 60 000 people in the palm of their
hands he was like if she had said
everyone turn to the person next to you
and kill them like they would have
that's like Kingsman yeah he was like it
was so crazy yeah yeah
well great weekend for Taylor great
weekend for everyone for mothers for
everyone I agree it was a good weekend I
feel like
karmically for everyone except for these
next two people who you're gonna explain
explain for us um before I'm in in the
story that is numbered number four
before Claudia Explains It All let me
explain that today's episode is brought
to you by ZipRecruiter please do whether
you're starting a new business or
growing one if you want to be successful
you need the most talented people on
your team and that's why Jackie hired me
and she found my application on
ziprecruiter.com you can try
ZipRecruiter now for free when you go to
ziprecruiter.com toast so why should you
choose uh ZipRecruiter to hire for your
business well supercruiter's powerful
matching technology finds highly
qualified candidates for a wide range of
roles if you've got your eye on one or
two people who'd be perfect for your job
ZipRecruiter actually lets you send them
a personal invitation so they're more
likely to apply ZipRecruiter also offers
attention-grabbing labels that speak to
the job flexibility so if you offer
remote if you offer training if it's an
urgent position it will really help your
job stand out and get your job listing
into the hands of the right candidates
so let zip recruiter fill all your roles
with all the right candidates it's so
important that you're constantly hiring
like good efficient people who you know
who you respect who you know have the
right skill set I'm sure that's why when
you saw my listing on ZipRecruiter you
were like that's the girl I knew
immediately yeah that was the turdy Lou
for me and I would just kind of change
your whole business right yes as you
have in so many ways when I saw your
listing I was like oh this looks like a
fun fabulous work environment yes and I
want to be a part of this important
toxic work environment right
so see for yourself go to our exclusive
link of ziprecruiter.com toast and
you'll be able to try ZipRecruiter for
free again that's ziprecruiter.com
t-o-a-s-t ZipRecruiter the smartest way
to hire
today's episode is also brought to you
by Caraway get a head start on spring
cleaning with Caraway their thoughtfully
designed sets and complimentary storage
makes getting and staying organized
easier than ever you can now save 10 off
the full Suite of Caraway products from
their internet famous cookware to their
newly launched food storage sets get
caraway's high quality ceramic coated
kitchenware it is free of PTFE like
Teflon lead cadmium other toxic
materials caraway's kitchenware comes in
a variety of chic Shades and all the
sets include complementary easy access
storage solutions Jax I know you're a
girl who appreciates a Caraway obsessed
I know you are Caraway like I literally
preach anything else ever it's the best
one because it's not toxic so like all
these other like non-stick sub like
products have all these top other issues
okay they're not sticking but you're
talking right right it's one or the
other one or the other Caraway has none
of that it's good for you it's also
nonstick like it's crazy how you just
like put it under the same and
everything's gone it's so easy to clean
especially if you have like a husband or
just like you live with someone who
doesn't just like do the dish when it's
done it's like you've got egg on it for
six hours it still won't stick yeah
Caraway is there for people like Ben and
it's also gorgeous so like if you make a
gorgeous chili you don't even have to
put it in a nice bowl like you just put
it with Caraway they give you those
little Heat Protector cork pads like the
glass surface protector thing and dinner
is served order up
visit carawayhome.com toast10 to take
advantage of this limited time offer for
10 off your next purchase this deal is
exclusive for toasters so visit
carawayhome.com toast10 or use code
toast10 at checkout Caraway non-toxic
cookware made Modern that's toast 10
t-o-a-s-t10 it's also pretty enough to
just leave out on your stove so you
don't need extra storage for the big pot
that's so true you know yeah big pop big
pot
next story Jeremy Allen White's wife
Addison Timlin files for divorce after
more than three years of marriage now I
just want to say I've never heard of
either of these people until this
morning so but Claudia tells me this is
a big deal for people who have it's a
very Niche story but like if you care
you care let me tell you why and that
those are some of the best stories yes
okay the try guys exactly for anyone
who's watched Shameless Jeremy Allen
White is like the older brother he's so
hot like if you watch a show like you're
just in love with him okay okay but like
in a very you know tortured artist kind
of way and everyone was just kind of
like who's Jeremy Allen going to like
date you know and then like a few years
ago it was like oh he's actually gonna
marry this girl they have a baby and
it's like it's not that exciting they're
very private and it's like I mean you
know Hearts were breaking everywhere
when Jeremy Allen White announced this
but you know people are into it they
have like a very artsy life they're
always like taking artsy photos and
they're very private but they give
people a little bit and people started
to scan it was really sweet they just
like had a baby fell in love and like he
wasn't gonna you know play the Hollywood
dating game and we were crushed but we
were happy for him and then yesterday
his wife posted on Instagram for
Mother's Day like talking about being a
single mom
and we're like wait what you're married
no you're not
he commented like supportive you know
but they're not together anymore they're
not together and it was a very hard
launch of a divorce she filed for
divorce people has confirmed she filed
on Thursday according to court documents
which is like a little crazy that then
she posted to Instagram on Sunday well
yeah because if you file on Thursday
like
are you a single mom no
that was a different question that you
had but I'm just saying like they got
away with their filing nobody was
looking right so like they could have
they wanted people to learn unless
they've been separated for so long
they're like how did you just not figure
it out here we go right right right but
they do have two uh daughters Ezra and
Dolores
so I just can't hear the name Dolores
without thinking of Catania like she
owns that name
um this is you know this is sad it's
always sad when a family breaks up you
know
he commented so it's clear that they're
not you know any bad blood or anything
hey stop she wasn't doing anything
now it obviously just like opens the
door for you know who does Jeremy Allen
White date next Taylor Swift
okay he's like I think way shorter than
her he's like not that tall Taylor's so
tall so underrated she might even be
like a little taller than Matt Healy but
it doesn't really matter because he's
still tall
Jeremy Allen White is like a short King
but he's like really hot okay
and he's like I think he's also like
he's 32. oh okay she's what 30 like 3 or
32. yeah
um 1989. right do the math three
depending on her birthday it's December
33 33. it's still it's not it's not a
match okay
he's very artsy like his Instagram is
all black and white she likes artists
yeah but like I think he might consider
her like two mainstream you know he
sounds like he's like he gives me like
toxic NYU student Vibes you know okay
like the kids in my class let me check
my list I don't know if I have any art
girls you also do need to update the
list do you know who's art girl that's
single who
this is so random but just because it's
art
um
John mulaney's ex-wife Anna Marie tenler
okay like I don't know if is it too much
art I don't know she gives me like older
Vibes how old is she Google
maybe she just gives you that Vibe
because she was like married for a while
yeah she is 37. okay
she's short we love that we could add
her to the list okay girls Jeremy Allen
White and Chloe no Aza Gonzalez no
Selena Gomez no Lori Harvey
I don't hate it but continue Minka Kelly
is dating someone right she was last
seen with the Imagine Dragons singer Dan
and they were like we haven't heard
anything okay question mark next to her
name apparently she just came out with a
memoir that is so good really I I saw
that it's the best celebrity Memoir of
the year
whoa yeah gotta add it to my I love her
by the way when I was driving through
Fresco basically all there is in frisco
is car dealerships I'm Jeremy Allen's
girlfriend and I just want to say I felt
like Lila Garrity continue Florence Pugh
so it's settled he'll marry Florence
case closed the end
I'll put him on the list just in case
because it's nice to know like who's not
even if she starts dating someone like
he's not wiped up yeah no he's like an
interesting fellow you only get off the
list really like when you get engaged I
agree
um so speaking of the list and eligible
people our fifth and final story are
kind of like the two most eligible
bachelor's Metro getting together and
being together in a very real way who
Kendall Jenner and Magic oh yeah sit
courtside at the Lakers playoff game
amid rumored romance stop calling it a
woman like no they literally like made
out on the horse out on the court it's
not a rumor they went to Coachella
they've been spot on like 11 dates amid
romance they literally are like always
leaving a party together like they're
they couldn't have been more clear with
us there's and we're all sitting here
being like well are they it's a rumor
that they're together oh my God why do
they keep calling it that seriously I
don't know I need to understand it's
infuriating so they were photographed
side by side in High Spirits at the
Lakers versus Golden State Warriors
playoff game on Friday oh I guess that's
who's also in the playoffs
um or the super good matchup California
yeah it's been like very Buzzy yeah
because the Kardashians were there
that's why but also because it's like La
yeah and the Lakers
fans on the other team yeah yeah oh and
I think LeBron is on the Lakers right
yeah that sounds right so it's like very
Buzzy very Buzzy yeah hard to get
tickets Kendall and bad were both
wearing snakeskin boots
um what does it mean what does it mean I
wonder if they coordinated that like
it's kind of cool or are just like
snakeskin boots like so in right now
that like do you think when you're in a
celebrity couple you coordinated that
your stylists like might talk about what
you guys are wearing at this level of
dating I would be I would be shocked if
they do at this level of dating I
understand if you're like a couple a
solidified couple engaged certainly
married yeah but like
to be in a rumored romance like we're
gonna coordinate outfits I kind of think
it's just a coincidence yeah that's fair
um but this just whole week or like two
the Kardashians have been at like every
game like with North and they're like
rooting for Tristan yeah so Kim in North
went to the Lakers game and North had a
sign yeah they said Tristan and I guess
it's a cue because like
he's like kind of her uncle in like a
weird way like like not but like yeah
yeah and true sad it's and it's her
cousin's dad so do you think that this
means anything like in terms of Chloe
and Tristan
I'm gonna say no okay because Chloe
would have been there and like why not
Chloe go to one game right actually I
don't think she could deal with the the
pressure that when she used to go to
LaMar's games she would say like every
time that she went people would be like
they lost Chloe's a curse and she would
talk on the on the show about her like
it really made her feel bad that's one
thing but another is just Chloe doesn't
like being in the public eye anymore
like when you watch new Kardashians like
she had so much anxiety around red
carpets even when they like went to
Miami just like walking from the car to
the restaurant like those pictures give
so she's not gonna sit Courtside and be
evaluated for three hours yeah but North
is like taking a front you know a pro
Tristan she's no she's taking like a
main character role in the family these
days between like her Tick Tock and like
Kim takes her everywhere now maybe she
Kim thinks she's like old enough for it
but like she's kind of like putting the
family on her back yeah she would say so
for sure for sure so with Nori's black
book yeah uh but it feels like an
intentional shift like Kim has like put
North now like very forward-facing
she brought her to that award that yes
and she stole the show yeah and they had
that like High Fashion Week in Milan
right like last year
yeah it's like maybe it's like a like a
Coming of Age like like about myth nine
no I know
I don't know I just think it's like
these are North's interests and then
everything that like North and Kim do
attracts attention maybe maybe you know
yeah
because then she's also just a kid going
to Katy Perry with her friends so true
on a private chat and going on stage now
you know Taylor's tour takes la like she
I think she's doing like seven shows
maybe six
um and it's just been so interesting
because there are so many celebrities
who like outwardly love Taylor but there
are so many celebrities who have like
been very outspoken in their dislike for
her had beef with her beef with her who
she has beef with right right like Katy
Perry's been resolved like she has beef
with Kim she's beef with like Demi
Lovato she's like beef with the most
random people she has beef with um pink
which is like so weird like Pink Just
Like went off on her and watched Robin's
live one year
um and La is like this obviously this
Hub of celebrity and I'm so curious to
see like which celebrities will be at
the LA shows like Kim has been like
posting videos over the last like two
years where she's like working out or
getting Glam and in the background
there's like Taylor Swift music playing
like almost feeling like intentional
yeah I feel like the only way that any
of the Kardashians like go to Taylor
Swift is like if Chloe takes some of the
girls because Chloe listens to her the
most oh it's done like what I've seen
okay and also like her vibe like Chloe's
Vibe is very like lover Taylor yeah you
know so true um and so I don't think Kim
Kim cannot go Kim could not but and I
don't think they could go like they're
they could be patrons of Sofi Stadium I
could buy a box on the Asos like own the
State stadium right and that's their
family friends yeah so yeah they could
just like get a box like buy tickets it
doesn't have to be like a coordinated
they don't have to talk to Taylor's Camp
Tree pain it's not like Taylor's camp
and Kim's Camp got you know together
tree and Tracy don't have to talk right
right right I would love if they did but
I don't think that they will
um so they can go and it can mean
nothing yeah just like the girls like
Taylor Swift right we're not going to
deny them because of the parents draw
like there's no way none of the
grandkids most of them are girls don't
like there's not one of them who's not a
super fan
yeah like I could so see Penelope being
like a super fan no Penelope seems more
um is that she's in a reputation era
yeah
totally but I feel like she's yeah she's
more like into like Travis's music than
she would be yeah maybe like dream no or
um
like true Chicago yeah even North if
North likes Katy Perry like yeah how
would she not like Taylor unless she's
not allowed to listen to it right is
there like an embargo in the house I
don't think they would do that either
because keep listens yeah I just don't
know how you could be like a fan of
things and not be a fan of Pop of Taylor
Swift yeah no I think if it's gonna
happen Chloe takes some of the kids
that's a good prediction yeah maybe one
other maybe like maybe Courtney honestly
like Courtney's like such a mom she
doesn't care about anything other than
her kids happiness like I know but I
don't think I think Chloe's more of a
Taylor fan than yeah than Courtney would
be and maybe Chloe goes with like Malika
do Kendall and Taylor have beef well
Kendall and Taylor we're friends friends
at one point like via Gigi yeah but she
went on stage at 19 yeah yeah which is
so crazy so maybe like Chloe and Kendall
take the girls or Chloe but I feel like
Kendra stormaloo loves her for sure I
think actually in terms of all the girls
who are like the weirdest relationship
with Kendall like I mean with with
Taylor Kendall's is probably the
weirdest like up there with Kim because
they were friends because they were
friends and you know in Paris the song
on midnights I like feel like that
opening line your ex-friend's sister met
someone at a club and he kissed her
turns out it was a guy you hooked up
with ages ago some wanna BC Lister I
just feel like that's your ex-friend's
sister like okay oh so she's it's Taylor
is your yeah by the way the context of
the song is like somebody's saying this
to Taylor
okay she's like did you hear and then
Taylor's like no I didn't but thanks
though okay so your ex-friend's sister
Kendall Kendall sister no your ex-friend
is Kim oh no sorry yeah your ex-friend
is Kendall sister any of them any of
them was hit a club yeah and maybe that
would someone a BC Lister
Kylie I don't know it could be anyone
yeah
I just feel like there's a lot of
weirdness I feel like an underrated
weird relationship is Kendall and Taylor
everyone says Kim and Taylor but Kendall
was friends with her when that whole
thing went down
no but then Gigi's in this like weird
ass place where like she's really good
friends with Kendall but of course like
sisters with Taylor same with her and uh
Selena because Selena was spotted out
like a few times with Zane yeah
but like Kendall and Gigi are like so
right no sorry I can't keep these
people's names
Gigi and Taylor are like sisters like
there's no breaking them up yeah but
there is a lot of crossover then like
Kendall and Haley are such good friends
but
Haley Selena Taylor yeah Taylor there's
like young Hollywood is
Haley right
Gigi and then there's the other layer of
the weekend
Haley
no Selena Taylor Bella like it's just it
never ends yeah incestuous yeah but
Taylor's just kind of like
like out of it you know yeah I mean
she's 33 I think she knows who her real
friends are right I think she doesn't
she's probably like most people like I
don't care to make more friends like and
she has a really big group and circle of
friends with so many people and it's
gotten smaller like right like I'm good
but I don't think that keeps her up like
how am I gonna win Campbell's friendship
you know every time like she's seen out
with a celeb or like someone has come to
the show she doesn't like do that girl
getting thing anymore so I don't really
know like who she's on good terms with
so it's like I was so happy to see
Jennifer Lawrence and her good she hangs
out within her time off like when she
was walking down the street with the
Hames and you know those people are
obvious but like Jennifer Lawrence
you know but like she was at the show
this weekend like they're good it's nice
to see because there was like the
breakup of that girl group you know
which Jennifer Lawrence in it no she's
kind of irrelevant and actually she's
hugely close with the Kardashians right
right I guess you're like you could have
friends who don't get along I think
that's extremely mature yeah as long as
they don't bother you about it right
look at you involved oh leave me alone
yeah so toxic
um set sort of past five I feel like all
of them were you needed to know all them
except that about Kelly those
lies were just yeah you didn't need to
know the lies but you do need to know
that people are telling lies about Kelly
and that so that you can be in a
position to defend her lying on her name
yeah
and that's our show that is our show
anything else before we wrap no head
over to toastmerch.com to see the mama
collection and the Bebe collection and
head over to patreon.com to see the Vlog
from the ACM Awards a lot of you know
lots of celebs in there Dolly Parton
makes an appearance can't wait yeah me
too I love you love you we're getting
lunch yeah what should we get let's get
something different look at the same
thing we get every day I can't eat the
same thing that you eat every day that's
like just kind of my life I have the
same two meals every two distinct like
you've got to switch it up
yeah
we'll think we'll wind up getting the
same thing but don't think about it
thanks so much listening to the Justin
Morning Show we do the thoughts that you
need to know everybody the Friday on
YouTube so you're watching this on
YouTube please don't forget to subscribe
give this video thumbs up also available
podcast
books all the places and podcast find us
the Josephine five star review about a
beautiful stand again what talented we
are hope you guys have an amazing Monday
and we'll see you tomorrow for the day
that comes after Monday which is four
three by Tuesday love you bye